all right so uh just so you understand
these moves a little more closely all
right so this one you you're going to
get a displacement action by going
straight but as you turn it you get
bigger displacement action and then once
it's turned you're going to come in and
get CED right
there so that's the first move so the
the first move is very quick that that's
the first move just cut off that thumb
area
Okay uh he feel he he'll feel the
pressure so as I'm coming in who he's
going to crack my head open crack okay
that's where we're
at
okay and my view here is I'm going to
catch his sword that that's all I'm
going to do is I'm going to catch his
sword I'm going to do I adhesion on the
sword
okay on Boom catch
down just like all adhesions cat boom
take his take his center with it
okay at the angle I did ten con and I'm
just here on top of his sword just
sticking to it that's all I'm doing
okay I'm not going here and knocking it
down
[Applause]
catch
catch make sure you catches Center you
his Center okay and we're off Angle now
only thing is that I have his Center he
doesn't
have boom
when you catch you don't catch the the
tuba you want to catch the spine of his
sword okay the spine of his
[Applause]
sword come on head
i s is up on my Center the whole time go
back
slow boom it's with my Center the whole
time stays with my
Center
down don't come left right stay with
your Center
boom okay let's